MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Wes.
WESLEY CHUN: Hi, Martin.
What are we doing today?
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, last
week, you showed me your weather
alerting app.
You said you'd
like to optimize it
by pulling the
values from a cache
instead of hitting an
external API every time.
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
And I read up on the
new CPU allocation
controls in Cloud Run.
So let's do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: All right, Wes.
Could you walk us through
your weather alerting app?
WESLEY CHUN: Yes, of course.
When I enter a US state
abbreviation in this text
field, the app hits
api.weather.gov to get
the weather alerts
for that state
and then displays
them to the user.
MARTIN OMANDER: Nice.
WESLEY CHUN: As you can
see, it's a web app.
And I didn't want to
maintain any servers
or virtual machines.
So I deployed it to Cloud Run.
It's running pretty well.
MARTIN OMANDER: So Wes, I'd
imagine weather alerts don't
change second by second.
So is there an opportunity
to cache these alerts?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
That's a great idea, Martin.
By caching those
weather alerts, the app
can respond faster to users and
our bandwidth bill is reduced.
We also use up less computing
resources for our friends
at weather.gov.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds
like a win-win-win.
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, that's right.
So I want to cache the weather
alerts for all 50 states.
Well, I could schedule a
job with Cloud Scheduler
that updates this cache
every five minutes.
But now with Cloud Run,
and it's always on CPU,
we don't have to do that.
Normally, Cloud Run
throttles the CPU
after your service
has responded.
But with this new
feature, we can
keep the CPU at full capacity
for background tasks,
like updating my cache.
And on top of that, we get
a discounted rate, too.
MARTIN OMANDER: I can see
how an always-on CPU would
be useful for other things
beyond updating caches, too.
For example, OpenTelemetry
tries to send
tracing data to the server
when the CPU is less busy.
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, that's right.
This is useful for
[? goroutines, ?]
node async calls, Java threads,
Kotlin coroutines, and Spring
Boot background functionality.
MARTIN OMANDER: I'm sold.
Let's do it.
WESLEY CHUN: All right.
Well, first, I'll
edit my Cloud Run
service in the Cloud Console.
Then I select "CPU is always
allocated" and then redeploy.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
That was easy, Wes.
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
And now in my code, I'm
going to add a loop here
that updates the cache
every five minutes.
MARTIN OMANDER: And you've
implemented updateCache
further down in the code?
WESLEY CHUN: Yep, down here.
Take a look.
So I added all of this after
the standard get and post
processing.
Any viewers who are interested
can see the implementations
in the linked repo.
MARTIN OMANDER: Looks good.
Time to deploy?
WESLEY CHUN: Yep.
And here goes.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Looks like it's done.
I'll use the service to get
the weather list for California
now.
It looks like we
didn't break anything.
What do the logs say?
WESLEY CHUN: Let's see.
Well, here, I see
that the cache is
being updated for all 50
states outside of any requests.
And here, I see that the service
returned a response to you
and that it was
read from the cache.
It's working.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very nice.
How much will we pay for this?
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
regarding costs,
note that we are being billed
for more time, meaning rather
than just the time when
instances respond to requests,
we're now incurring costs for
an entire instance's lifetime,
meaning from when a
container is started
to when it's terminated.
On the other hand, we
get a big discount--
25% less for CPU,
20% less for memory--
and we won't be charged
per-request fees
for either requests
or background tasks.
MARTIN OMANDER: I like that.
How does CPU allocation
interact with Cloud autoscaling?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, Cloud Run's
autoscaling is still in effect
and may terminate container
instances if they aren't needed
to handle incoming traffic.
Also, an instance
will get shut down
15 minutes after processing its
last request unless it's kept
active using main instances.
Once your instance
gets shut down,
any background work
will also get killed.
In general, always-on CPU is
good for high and even loads
or if you want to
run background tasks.
Those background tests could
be your own code or libraries
like OpenTelemetry
or Spring Boot.
MARTIN OMANDER: Good to know.
Thanks, Wes.
And thank you for watching
all the way to the end.
If you have any
questions for Wes
or me about CPU
allocation in Cloud Run
or feedback on this
episode or suggestions
for future serverless
topics, please let us
know in the comments.
Bye for now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]